foreign
Falls in Sioux Falls South Dakota what's
up Alexandra
nothing much how are you doing Dr John
good you all having fun
you know it's like 50 some degrees here
today so no maybe not quite as much fun
as I hope
I'd hope that's like the depths of
winter here in Nashville very cool
so what's up can I jump right in with my
question let's do it
okay
so I typed it out so I wouldn't get too
tongue-tied perfect
um I'll go ahead
um how do I connect with my father who
I'm starting to resent
um a little bit of backstory so my dad
has drug induced schizophrenia he's had
it since he was in his 20s
um and he had my sister and I when he
was 28 and 29.
my parents divorced shortly after that
and he went to jail for a little while I
was six months old and my sister was a
year and a half
um growing up my dad lived with my
great-grandmother and we would go see
him at her house during this time he
cycled every three to five years so when
this would happen we would go a little
while without seeing him and we were
told that he was Ill not really
explaining anything else
um and then once he was doing better
we'd go back and see him like nothing
happened
I was about 16 when somebody finally
explained it to me that it was a mental
illness and explained to me a little bit
about what schizophrenia was and why we
were allowed around him at that time
um and so at 19 he had
he went off of his medication so he
cycled and
at that point I guess my family had kind
of decided that my sister and I were old
enough to figure it out by ourselves
um and with
literally no guidance at all
um we were able to help him get into
um checked into the ER because at 19 I
have no idea how to handle a mental
illness at all and so we went to the ER
because that was
what I guess we were supposed to do
um and so we got him a psych eval and
then got him put into a
I don't a behavioral health unit sure
where they got him back on his
medication and he got out a couple days
later and we went and got him brought
him back to my grandmother's house and
that's kind of how it's been
um ever since then we moved him up to
Sioux Falls he used to live in Iowa we
moved him up to Sioux Falls because we
thought maybe him being closer to us and
like seeing us more would be helpful to
him
um he's actually started the cycle now
every like couple months every two to
three months so he goes off of his
medication for two to three months
um and he hides it super well he doesn't
talk about it very often and he hates
whenever we bring it up and so usually
we just try not to
um and then we notice things we start
getting text messages about like needing
to run and hide and how people are after
him
um and then
it takes us about a month or so to
convince him to go back to behavioral
health
um get them checked in try to get them
back on track there is a program here
that you go to right after that right
after being in the hospital
and he never stays on it and so he's
good for about two to three months and
then we just start over again okay okay
listen listen listen listen
I'm hoping somebody's told you
everything I'm about to tell you okay
is that cool
yeah
this isn't the way this is supposed to
be
foreign
you deserved a dad who was fully present
with you who held you like the princess
you were because you were his baby girl
and who dedicated his life to making
sure your life was good
and you deserved a dad who was going to
hold you
and every day despite your protests tell
you that you were beautiful and that he
loved you
and despite your protest he was going to
look you in the eye and say I'm so glad
that of all the crazy people in the
world God picked me to be your dad
foreign
but I need you I need you to hear this
Direct
the dad you missed growing up was not
your fault
the dad you missed growing up was
because he was sick not you
and you have spent a long long time
trying to bridge that Gap to a
relationship back to him because your
little six month old and seven-year-old
and 12 year old and 19 year old body is
trying to tell you somehow this is your
fault
if you would just fill in the blank move
him closer pay more closer attention to
his meds maybe he moves in
all of this language that Cycles to your
head over and over is that somehow you
need to be doing something different and
the dead can be okay
and that's not true
goodness
am I wrong
no you're not
okay I want you to do me a huge favor I
want you to take as deep a breath as you
possibly can and hold it
three two let it out and I want you to
drop your shoulders all the way down
okay
I could feel them creeping up to your
ears
okay
schizophrenia is the devil
because it takes the people that we love
away from us
and they're there in body
and they look at us and you've been with
your dad when he's off his meds when
he's off cycle
and he's looking right at you but he
doesn't see you you know what I mean
yeah absolutely it's terrifying isn't it
absolute worst
the Temptation should we go from here
you're not gonna like what I have to say
okay and I want you to know if you hang
up this phone you say that guy sucks I'm
totally okay with that okay my promise
is I'm just never gonna not tell you the
truth okay I also know that it's easy
for me to say what I'm about to say
because I don't have this challenge in
my house
and I can't honestly say hi I would
respond if I was in your same boat okay
but you cannot be the person responsible
for keeping your dad well
you can't
you can't check up on him every 30
minutes and make sure he's on his meds
you can't make sure that when he stops
taking his meds that he doesn't have
access to phones and stuff because he's
gonna go fill in the blank fill in the
blank fill in the blank you cannot make
your dad be healthy and whole and I'm so
sorry
in a season when he is on meds
and he's it sounds like he levels out is
that fair
yeah okay
when he levels out
there has to be some sort of
conversation which is Dad if you get off
of your medication
you are making a choice to no longer be
in my life and my sister's life
and I miss you and I want you in our
life and I hope that you will never make
that choice
but when he's on his meds he understands
that his brain's not telling him the
truth
does he
okay okay it just turns the turns the
volume of the alarms down a little bit
so this is the thing that I get a little
bit confused about
um
he was discharged from the military when
he was 18 I think okay and what they had
told him was that he had multiple
personality disorder or something like
that and then he got the diagnosis of
schizophrenia
and the thing that I don't understand is
normally like you said medication turns
the volumes down
um he actually liked being off of his
mess like he oh dude yes I've never met
a schizophrenic person that's not true
maybe one who enjoyed being on their
medication
foreign
because there's this impending sense
that
um it's like being in a room full of
crowded people with headphones on you
know they're talking
and they might be talking about me
but I'm wearing headphones because I
can't take the volume
you get that you know that that how that
would just gnaw at you you know I know
they're talking and I wonder what
they're saying but I do know this if I
listen to what they're saying I go
insane
I hurt myself and other people
and so my path forward is one of two
choices
being like sticking my head into the
fire or choosing to not listen to what's
going on in the world around me
and so the tension is there I've met one
person who enjoyed being was able to
um
preferred being in relationship then
then
being on the inside of this radical
information they had right
but that's a and I don't know what kind
of I don't know enough about the
neurophysiology of schizophrenia and the
schizotypal disorders and all the
different little nuances of that my
guess is their brain lesions were a
little bit different are their brain
chemistry is a little bit different
um no it's a it's a choice it's a battle
it's a war because you feel this
impending sense of dude they're coming
and you are choosing not to look that's
what that feels like
and yes so what you're suggesting
is that when he's off of this medication
no on on oh oh go ahead go ahead I cut
you off go ahead
one trip with my sister and I
um but when he chooses to be on it and
that's the other thing is
if
we've tried that before where like
if he's off of his medication we're
still talking to him but we're not
pushing him to go
get evaluated we're not pushing him to
go to the hospital and so I mean nobody
is then
it just doesn't happen and then so this
happened two weeks ago he disappeared
for seven days yep left his phone left
his car left everything just gone
dropped off the base of the planet
um and I filed a missing person's report
on him and he showed up seven days later
that he was living in the woods
he enjoyed it out there but he came back
because he needed his phone
can I tell you it sounds like this is
escalating
yeah
I just at some point at some point you
go sit down
um
with the local care services and or
whatever go back to the the hospital you
had him admitted to originally
and ask about the procedure in your
particular state for an involuntary
committal
because it sounds like he is fast on a
path to not being able to take care of
himself
and you have to recognize your
limitations you do not have the ability
to deal with the level of psychosis your
father has
okay and that's a powerless feeling
we've gone through that four times this
year okay we've done this this
involuntary commitment okay we just
keeps cycling and so how many how many
times do you no I would ask for I would
I would ask for what does a court order
look like to make this a permanent
residency
the hospital no no no a long-term care
Treatment Center
for somebody with psychosis who's unable
to care for themselves
and if he's a threat to himself or
others there's a possibility that you
can get him committed
long term
and I would pursue that if I'm in your
exact shoes because here's the deal you
can't solve this you can't fix it
right and it sounds like if he's
continuing to get off his meds and he's
cycling more and more and faster and
faster and now he's disappearing for two
days and now it turns into seven days
and now it turns into see what I'm
saying this is on a trajectory that is I
don't like
and you and you are gonna have you and
your sister are gonna have to fight the
impulse to blame yourself for the
trajectory because it's not your fault
right your dad's not doing well
in fact the greatest gift you could give
your dad is for you to be whole
and when he's on his meds
and he has a conversation with you those
rare conversations where everything's
light everything he can maybe make some
jokes he remembers the old days
you think to yourself there he is there
he is there's the real him I can go get
him
I can go get him there
and unfortunately that's not their whole
real him because the whole real him is
very very sick
and it's easy to live in a fantasy and
even when he's cycled off and you
continue to talk to him and you continue
to talk to him and you continue to talk
to him
you're just heading down a bottomless
pit with somebody
and I know it's your dad and I I know
it's so hard I know it's so hard
especially given the years of abuse you
suffered
but the wise mature thing here is to
step back take 10 Paces back and put
your hands up and say I don't have the
expertise
to heal my dad
I don't have the expertise or the
financial wherewithal or even the
ability
to continue to prop my father up for 5
10 15 20 years however long this is
going to go and this is starting to
cycle faster and faster and faster and
he's going to end up
um
you know hurting himself or somebody
else
so it's time for me to call in folks who
could care for him long term
and let's go down that road and see what
that's going to look like I don't know
what that looks like in Sioux Falls my
guess is they've got some significant
resource opportunities there but that's
where I would go
and remember remember
it's not your fault
it's not your fault